هذه الفكره الفنيه التي تفتق عنها ذهن
المصور الفوتوغرافي الن هانسون قد تكلفه
غاليا واكثر من مليون دولار كغرامات
هانسون لالتقاط صور لامراه كانت بصحبته
وهي عاريه الصدر في منصه المراقبه باعلى
برج امباير ستيت اصابت الزوار بالذهول
وتعتبر ناطحه السحاب من ابرز معالم مدينه
نيويورك وتجذب منصه المراقبه باعلى البرج
ملايين السياح سنويا واعترض بعض هم بالقول
هناك عائلات واطفال انه ليس بالمنظر
الملائم وتتفق اداره المبنى مع هذا الراي
وقررت رفع دعوه قضائيه ضد هانسون بدعوه
عدم حصوله على تصريح لالتقاط صوره عاريه
بمنصه المراقبه مؤكدين في الوقت ذاته
بانهم ما كانوا ليسمحوا بهذا العمل غير
الملائم وتطالب الاداره بغرامه قدرها
مليون و100 الف دولار من هانسون واما
محاميه فيقول ان التقاط صوره عاريه باعلى
البرج معلم ليس مخالفا
للقانون